Hollywood is a crazy world with an even
crazier history
it's conniving competitive and above all
risky I think to analyze movies it's
important to understand the context
surrounding the production of the movie
not to mention it's also extremely
interesting
so let's separate Hollywood's life into
five distinct eras and see the thievery
desperation and failure in the industry
starting with the first movies actually
began far away from Hollywood California
all movies before 19/11 like the Great
Train Robbery and the first Frankenstein
movie were filmed entirely on the East
Coast in fact the all-too-familiar term
cliffhanger most likely originates from
a series called the peril of poly in
1914 which was filmed in the former
motion picture capital of the country
Fort Lee New Jersey the move to
Hollywood happened for several reasons
it was cheaper there was nice weather
year-round and California provided a lot
of distinct film locations nothing
illustrates this better than Paramount's
description of the region one reason
hardly talked about however is the fact
that these million dollar motion picture
industries were fleeing to California so
they could more easily break the law in
1891 Thomas Edison patented the kinetic
graph the technology used to film movies
with his patent he had a legal monopoly
on the entire industry even had control
over movie projectors and film
distributors Edison aggressively sued
many people using his invention going so
far as to hiring thugs to smash cameras
and raid independent studios filmmakers
like Fox and paramount had to flee to
the west coast so they could make their
movies outside of Edison's influence so
technically any movie made before 1917
not from Thomas Edison's production
company was completely illegal in 1917
the United States Supreme Court ruled
his monopolies unlawful and against
public interest it's interesting how an
industry founded on breaking the rules
is now aggressively taking video essays
down on YouTube despite their obvious
fair use but I digress shall we try it
right food which cigar mr. Gordon
by the late 1910s America cinema
transitioned into what we're familiar
with the booming Hollywood industry the
industry skyrocketed a key innovation
was the addition of dialogue in the late
1920s which kept the industry afloat
popular and innovative throughout the
Great Depression the era between 1917 in
the late 1940s is commonly referred to
as studio system Hollywood this is when
production companies had decade-long
contracts with actors directors and
writers if you think the movie industry
is monopolized now know that five
studios had control of absolutely
everything in the 1940s each major
company had ownership of actors
directors distribution and even the
movie theaters creators could only make
it an industry if they stuck with one
company for almost their entire careers
by signing long term and sometimes very
unfair contracts out of this era came
classics such as Gone with the Wind Snow
White and the Seven Dwarves and the
original King Kong one interesting
aspect of this time period is that with
so many movies being made and so many
people flocking to the theater movie
companies could afford producing movies
with medium sized budgets and scripts
that weren't necessarily blockbuster
material like Citizen Kane and
Casablanca nowadays big companies pull
most of their time and resources into
several big-budget movies a year which
is quite a shame
the end of this era came from another
battle with the courts the Supreme Court
ruled against Paramount Pictures saying
ownership of the theaters and
distribution of their films was a
restriction of fair trade this loss of
control of distribution protected
independent filmmakers but meant to
decline in the big industry the next
head to movie popularity was television
television hurt the industry since many
people could stay at home to get their
entertainment movie viewership plummeted
in the 30s 60% of people went to the
movie theaters at least once a week but
since the 1960's the number has
consistently stuck around only 10
percent to combat TV movies had to do
what TV couldn't do big screens and big
budgets the Hollywood epic came into
fruition this is when movies got
absolutely insane cinema scope lenses
stretched the screen to almost twice the
size of conventional film there were
movies like Cleopatra in 1963 which was
the highest grossing film of the year
and still didn't make back its budget
one of his huge hundred-foot set pieces
had to be built twice in two separate
countries because the lead Elizabeth
Taylor got sick soon the new Hollywood
era broke through starting with Bonnie
and Clyde film school train directors
gained major influence in the industry
as opposed to the producers of old
Hollywood with low-budget hits like jaws
by Steven Spielberg Star Wars by George
Lucas and the Godfather by Francis
Coppola producers gave more control to
the filmmakers who in turn produced more
provocative diverse and innovative
movies personally I find this atmosphere
the most conducive to amazing filmmaking
but it came at a price
with such freedom several films got way
out of hand many directors took their
power too far in movie budgets
skyrocketed out of control Apocalypse
Now is an extreme example there's a
documentary on the production process of
the movie called heart of darkness that
I absolutely recommend I cannot come
close to describing the mayhem of making
that movie in such a short video
hurricanes heart attacks a coup in the
country they filmed its crazy with
Apocalypse Now in 1979 in the box office
bomb Heaven's Gate in 1980 bankrupting a
huge production company producers
tightened their grip on filmmakers which
makes absolute sense what happened was
in the 70s all those filmmakers that did
get final cut the budgets grew and grew
and each one one after the other had a
financial disaster that almost tore down
the studio's if you treat the movie
industry like an actual business it's
definitely
one of the riskiest one movie the public
hates and it cripples the company
millions are on the line and with
continuously decreasing ticket sales
companies had to adapt now we're at the
movie industry as we know it today with
home video in the 90s and streaming
services like Netflix it's hardly worth
it to drive all the way to a movie
theater anymore so companies make a
handful of movies and promote them like
crazy superhero and fantasy movies
dominate box office sales because those
are the movies that are worth seeing on
the big screen movies like pop star and
the nice guys bomb this year because
they're light comedies and frankly I'm
willing to wait for them to come to
Netflix in a couple months what's
amazing about this era is that it gets
easier and easier to make feature-length
movies I bought a used DSLR camera
tripod memory card case and editing
software for less than $600 you don't
need a huge movie conglomerate to get
your voice heard and your art noticed
Hollywood becomes more and more obsolete
every day so pick up your iPhone hit
record and say action thanks for
watching here it is the cool slightly
trans for just a bit of a break from the
norm just a little something to break
the monotony of all that